welcome to this video playing of Walter
Walter seven wins four losses this is
quite quite a number of games already
come on let's torrent files i really
don't know this opening but fun to try
something something new wow the rookie
won like I really don't know that at all
should be sound I guess something like
that is right really is six I think I
think this is something that is played
Bishop g5 maybe or Bishop e3 I know that
the main continuation he is Queen a5
Queen a to business but I really have no
idea ok so it's playing the Queen to the
side huh ok push up a six now on or not
hmm one knight c6 yeah it's not like the
gruene felt is really it's that this is
the only main line opening that I have
never played in tournaments as Lagoon
father not because I don't don't because
I think it's bad or anything it's just I
never learned it and did I always felt
like it's a good idea to really know it
before before I could could venture it
oh so a six know if I can go a six right
why not suspect
okay so he's saying that he's going to
play here okay yeah I am I somehow get
your point not so great yeah a4 might be
tricky but on the other hand if I get in
night a five-night c4 I'm certainly all
right huh difficult opening as usual g5
is also an idea of course breaking
through but a4a for could be a problem
yeah of course this one and always comes
into consideration so where'd you go why
have to go here right but night c4 so
good square so it's not i'm not sure
about that is this so bad I mean he's
got this this deep on obviously it's a
good fat but I don't really feel that
threatened here many ideas I can also go
here first night for Roxy 3 and many
many moves but let's start with that
rookie form in the greenness is not
having many squares
can also go to see why this is a
situation where he cannot really take
maybe takes rook takes is definitely
good for black I mean would be very
weird if not okay
a very simple move that I didn't
appreciate to the fullest hmm not good
hmm
I don't I cannot really this is pure
calculation should be five trying to get
the porn but i'm not sure if i get it
should be five hats not really good
right he will take here this is I have
underestimated d6 greatly I Bishop e7
most I mean we should be seven nights
before I should have played looking for
immediately that definitely was ok for
black I think I would would be
surprising if it wasn't ok
but this is probably just losing but I
didn't see any of any anything good he
can take and play monkey one that sets
really a problem
maybe I can hang on with Roxy 5 somehow
okay not not great at least I the sea
pawn gives me some activity c2 to get
get out of the pin of course I didn't
see the move great really great time
morning I can even play Queen a seven
here
Queen a seven I have no move whatsoever
okay chaddesden dead one now i
understand it ah what the game i really
didn't see anything here wow black
resigns Jim and I really think that
around here should be okay shouldn't it
I mean here I really can't believe this
okay looking for is good for lucky I was
thinking this I saw the move of course
but I really think that I think that
should be some was really good young I
can even go here because this wins yeah
but we shouldn't be seven I really this
is now really problematic especially
with no time computer still likes me
likes black but it's it's not easy yeah
this is not good very likely because
this is just totally hanging position
now okay and I mean maybe this is not so
bad yeah the compass on equal it doesn't
surprise me really that the sea porn is
strong but I immediately screwed it up
with allowing rugby sandwiches of course
very very yeah really really bad you
just have to go here and then maybe then
this move grr okay you can just read out
the computer evaluation as equal which
tells you that black is probably having
compensation but it's not easy to do
this is what the computer gives us a s
line yeah okay there's always this so
it's difficult for y2 to get anything
going yes to cover be to all the time
yeah but I really deserved lost ya even
blundered the Queen at the end Wow okay
thanks for watching